The first thing we have to do is actually test whether or not the boundaries of
this style intersect with the boundaries of the view rectangle. Now if you look
online you can actually find some really nice blocks of code that are 2D
rectangle to 2D rectangle testing. Effectively we're playing the same principle
here. We compute the boundaries of the x and y of the actual tile and world
space. And test this against our view rectangle boundaries as well. If the tile
lands outside of the viewRect, or it's not intersecting with the viewRect, then
it's not visible and we can move on. For those tiles that past this test, we
actually modify the worldX, and worldY translating it by the inverse of the
viewRect off set. What this is going to do is it's going to take our viewRect
and actually recenter it on the canvas itself, so that the worldX and worldY
coordinates are actually canvas oriented rather than world oriented. These
values are then passed down to canvas.drawimage directly and the image will
magically appear on the screen.